I've actually already tried to make this
video once but it didn't really work I
recorded about 8 minutes worth of
footage and when I was going through it
and trying to edit it I kept some going
that's not funny
what the hell what that doesn't make any
sense so when I went down from 8 minutes
worth of footage to 2 minutes worth of
footage I thought you know what I think
I'm gonna try this again so here we go
Charlie it's so Charlie yes so Charlie
is so cool so on Thursday next week I'm
going to be getting my GCSE results I
haven't really been thinking about it
and whenever anybody mentions you know
the words GCSE results I get kind of
freaked but just like any other teenager
from the UK I'm sure it's gonna be fine
I'll do fine and I know I'll be fine
56 caveman go zine 56 fan magazine if
you have no idea what 56 K magazine is
then go check out 56 K magazine.com it's
basically just a magazine written by
mainly youtubers about the internet and
YouTube stuff like that it's got lots of
lovely articles in it
my first time on YouTube article on
furries it's it's pretty damn funny and
it's well-written as well which is you
know miraculous seeing as it's written
by youtubers all youtubers are good for
his video blogging they can write to
what I didn't even think they could read
the best thing about this magazine
though was the free gift it came with a
renetto mask now I've already cut mine
out and everything but I've actually
lost it they have got a picture of it
which you can see now should be coming
up on your screens and you should be
watching it now and then it's going to
come off about now best thing is I was
talking to paper lilies and I might be
able to make the masks in the future but
that's only if the magazine you know
actually keeps going because it's
possible it might not it's only the
first issue so if you want it to do well
don't buy a copy it's very 2050 just
check out 56 okay magazine.com what else
is be going on
oh hey wolf died a while ago I'm gonna
play called Beowulf well I do have some
nice news for you just give me that one
of my friends who's also doing the play
with me that's lightning one of these
doohickeys Mike Cameron recorder yeah
yes so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
record back behind the scenes kind of
footage of Beowulf
the only thing is I'm not going to be
able to actually do any footage of the
actual performance because breaks
copyright what you call it but I'm going
to be taking as much footage as I can
and it should be cool
there's one thing though this camera
uses tapes I don't know if that's gonna
be a problem when uploading it to my
computer I think I can like convert it I
mean that shouldn't be too hard but I'm
a little bit worried that I might not be
able to put anything up digital video
cassettes I think that means I can
upload it but I just you could just
confirm that for me that'd be great
because I am a little bit skeptical it's
not going in the right way here and one
last thing
I hit nine thousand subscribers
yesterday I went up 1000 subscribers in
a week 1000 subscribers in a week I'm
going up pretty quick this will be
interesting I think that's about it see
you guys
you
look
it's a little woodlouse in a ball when I
was younger I used to actually eat wood
lice because I thought they were raisins
whoo I think it's milling come out of
your sphere little wood louse I think
it's correct dead r.i.p little wood
louse he was a brave little wood louse
took what came in life
he was beautiful never think that he did
do and oh I think he's coming back to
life
oh cool
you